alexis poulain éditorialistes alexis
poulain donc vous êtes avec nous bonsoir
43 minutes donc de conférence de presse
avec au début un point épidémique
d'olivier ferrand et puis ensuite les
véritables annonces qui ont été
divulguées par par jean castex nadége
abderrazak il vient de les énumérer
qu'est ce que vous retenez vous de
de sept de ces annonces au pluriel avec
donc ce couvre-feu on le rappelle qui
débutent mardi à un couvre feu nocturne
de 20 heures à 6 heures du matin donc un
peu plus strictes que le premier
couvre-feu
oui ah bah on retient ce moment de
spectacle un peu particulier où on
rabâche à la stratégie française tester
alerte et protégé où les mesures sont
toujours aussi loufoque avec ce
couvre-feu à ministre de l'intérieur qui
garde son sérieux pour dire qu'il faudra
bien être chez soi à 20h à tout faire
pour que ce soit 20 ans il le répète une
dizaine de fois avec toujours cette
autorisation de sortie et le ministre de
l'intérieur qui dit les gendarmes ont
utilisé les français selon vous c'est ça
complètement cetc continuer dans des
mesures idiote infantiliser les français
bien sûr les traiter comme des enfants
avec des mots clés comme ça dans le
gouvernement vous protège ils mettent
des amendes donc il vous protège
il nous protège de quoi de ne pas avoir
fait une autorisation pour sortir c'est
ridicule de ne pas aller vous tester à
benoît que ça pourrait engorger les
laboratoires donc on veut bien tester
mais pas avant noël
et puis cette phrase quand même de jean
castex un qui dit que toutes les études
scientifiques démontrent maintenant que
c'est bien la fête qui est un des grands
moments de propagation du virus
j'aimerais les voir ses études
scientifiques on a compris que le
gouvernement n'aimez pas la fête c'est
parce que des gens quelles ce texte les
digues qui l'adoré savais que c'était
compliqué c'était un vrai crève coeur
pour lui puisque les salles de cinéma de
théâtre les lieux qui accueillent du
public trois semaines encore de
fermeture que va-t-il se passer le 20
janvier aussi il a rappelé la date du 20
janvier où les restaurants seraient
censés réouvrir est ce qu'on va y
arriver
voilà un peu le suspense qui est devenue
celle de nos vie confinée
c'est à dire qu on est confiné on ne
peut pas vraiment sortir on a le droit
de sortir pour noël un peu pas plus de 6
à thise adultes à table c'est des
mesures cours à bâche alors il ya le bon
sens oui ce virus il existe oui il est
dangereux pour les personnes âgées dont
canton on aime ses parents ses proches
on fait attention de toute façon
naturelle pourquoi à mâcher pourquoi
mettre en place des mesures qui sont des
mesures de censure qui sont des mesures
de contrôle des populations et faire
croire qu'elle protège alors qu'en fait
non elles sont là pour imposer des
diktats sécuritaire le couvre-feu à 20
heures qu'est ce qui prouve ce
couvre-feu est utile le confinement
aussi qui a montré sa limite
et qui montre toujours ses limites et
puis il ya ce côté cocorico la france
on est les meilleurs parce qu'on est le
plus et par rapport aux voisins
européens il faut dire qu'on est les
meilleurs pour traiter cette épidémie
c'est faux rappelons-nous le fiasco des
masses qui étaient interdits à la vente
les pharmaciens ne pouvait pas vendre
des masques à l'époque quand vous
vouliez un masque pour aller à un rendez
vous médical vous ne pouviez pas
l'acheter dans la pharmacie
voilà c'est le même gouvernement c'est
un peu changé on a on a on a un peu
changé tout ça puisque jean castex est
arrivé entre deux mais olivier ferrante
c'était c'était lui qui était là qui a
géré cette crise de a à z on apprend
également que jérôme salomon avec cette
pression pour que des rapports sur
l'impéritie la façon dont cette crise
avait été extrêmement mal géré et ne
sortent pas rapport du sénat aussi qui
montre et pointe du doigt les
manquements les graves mensonges de ce
gouvernement et les voilà qu'ils nous
prennent pour des enfants ce soir à 18
heures en nous expliquant que la noël
c'est si sa table qu'il faut pas sortir
après 20 heures qu'il faut bien remplir
son attestation que si les gendarmes
nous mettre des amendes
c'est pour notre bien et que tout ça
c'est une gestion formidable et qu'il
faut applaudir des deux mains et que ça
s'appelle la solidarité
alexis plein jeu vous permet de vous de
vous couper pour écouter justement un
bout de jean castex qui a dit au début
un des mesures parfois incomprise il a
voulu expliquer que c'était pour limiter
le flux de population et pour éviter
évidemment un troisième confinement en
écoute jean castex t nous savons que les
fêtes de fin d'année à noël ou pour le
nouvel an constituent des moments
particulièrement à risque
le retour d'expérience de ce qui s'est
passé aux états unis ou au canada pour
les fêtes de thanksgiving le démontre
amplement puisque chaque fois c'est fait
ont entraîné une accélération de
l'épidémie
pour toutes ces raisons nous ne pouvons
pas baisser la garde
nous devons rester cohérent et négocier
les prochaines semaines avec beaucoup de
vigilance
nous devons adapter nos mesures autour
d'un objectif permettre à chacune et
chacun de profiter des vacances et des
fêtes de fin d'année mais sans nous
exposer à un risque de rebond de
l'épidémie ni maintenant ni dans les
premières semaines de janvier
car je pense que nous serons tous
d'accord sur ce point
faisons tout ce que nous pouvons pour
réduire le risque de devoir vivre un
troisième confinement dans les prochains
mois c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé
sous l'autorité du président de la
république d'adapter la stratégie de
déconfinement en pleine cohérence avec
ceux qui vous avait été présentée le 24
novembre dernier
on est tous d'accord pour éviter un
nouveau confinement après les faits ce
que vient de dire jean castex vous êtes
d'accord avec lui alexis poulain ah bah
on est tous d'accord pour 8 et un compte
non mais là ça fait quasiment un an
qu'on est confiné en pointillés ou qu'on
est faussement confiné parce que la
réalité c'est que ce deuxième confie
demandant n'était pas vraiment un
les écoles étaient ouvertes on pouvait
aider des messages par exemple falloir
trouver un emploi fictif pour pouvoir
sortir le soir par exemple puisqu'il ya
un couvre-feu
ben ça veut dire que dès beaucoup de
personnes font finalement du confinement
ne le respecte pas et écoute du
couvre-feu
oui oui parce que parce qu'il ya une
réalité qui est qu'on a du mal à croire
à la parole politique à croire à
l'efficacité de ces mesures compte tenu
finalement de la difficulté de les
comprendre puisque chaque semaine chaque
quinze jours on change on en est à la
quatrième édition de l'auto autorisation
de sortie par exemple rien que ça c'est
c'est complètement aberrant alors que
simplement rappeler aux français qu'il
suffit de respecter les mesures
barrières un peu de un peu de bon sens
nous simplement plutôt que ces mesures
coercitives qui ne servent à rien à part
prendre les français pour des idiots et
surtout leur faire porter la
responsabilité de cette épidémie qui
n'en finit pas justement vous venez de
parler des mesures barrières une
déclaration de
et veyran le test n'est pas un totem
contre l'immunité
donc du coup essayer de de prévenir
plutôt que de guérir
oui mais c'est ce langage de la télé de
la télé réalité alors on est on est
encore lente à quoi le test n'était pas
un totem contre l'immunité
on a l'impression d'un sketch vraiment
moi j'ai été admiratif de la façon dont
ils ont su garder leur sérieux pendant
cette conférence parce que jiri à
plusieurs reprises notamment gérald
darmanin qui rappelait les jeux de 20
heures à 20 heures faut être chez soi
attention rappelez vous cette histoire
de te thème les conclusions de jean
castex un peu on passait dans le jeu au
sein de la part de gérald darmanin
venait des automobilistes de l'intérieur
alors qu il alors du confinement du
deuxième confinement on évoquait de la
tolérance puisqu'on se souvenait c'était
la fin des vacances de la toussaint ici
pas d'indulgence pas de tolérance
non il s'agit de faire peur il s'agit de
contraindre il s'agit de faire
comprendre aux français que le
gouvernement est là pour les protéger en
leur faisant du mal c'est à dire on est
en évitant qu'ils aient des traitements
qui fonctionne ou qu'on essaye des
traitements qui pourraient marcher en
mettant des amendes tout le temps et
partout en ayant simplement des numéros
verts et en proposant simplement de
rester chez soi il ya eu très peu de
mots sur les soignants sur la façon dont
cela se sont organisés seul finalement
pour gérer cette pandémie sans l'aide de
l'état
c'est pas obligé vers ans qui les a
aidés dans la façon dont ils ont géré
cette crise bravo à eux par un pas un
mode merci pas vraiment et puis on
apprend que certains services comme
bidon simplement fermé à vire par
exemple un service commune a fermé ses
portes faute de patients donc on ne
comprend pas ces chiffres d'où ils
viennent comment ils sont faits on ne
comprend pas non plus les tests
puisqu'on nous dit que finalement avant
noël ça ne sert à rien de se faire
tester puisqu'il y aura pas de place et
et savent à engorger les laboratoires
donc allez-y soyez plus dans pas plus de
6 à table pas trop de homard et est
rentré chez vous pas de jour de l'an
bien entendu le réveillon ça s'est très
très mal donc
le couvre-feu à 20h et la salle pour
éviter un confinement en janvier de
toute façon je crois que en janvier on
n'évitera pas le pire c'est à dire que
c'était fini et là pour durer sur le
long terme donc finalement la conclusion
jean castex de dire les premiers mois on
aura droit au vaccin on aura droit à un
peu plus de test et on verra comment ça
se passe et puis bien sûr toujours stop
qu'ovide qui
très cher et qui a montré son
inefficacité encore une fois souligné
par rapport parlementaire donc une
conférence qui était encore une fois
l'art s'y faire peur aux français
merci alexis poulain